uh we have been covering a number of the
different conspiracy theories
speculations and reactions to different
aspects of what's been happening in
Ukraine this includes the so-called bio
weapons Labs bio Labs we've talked about
it Ad nauseam so far today I'm going to
scale up the crazy a little bit for you
Lara Logan is a now a Fox Nation host I
don't remember her full credentials at
one point I believe she was involved
with 60 minutes and
um a lot of different things have
happened with Lara Logan but she does
appear to have gone completely off the
deep end cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs and her
latest claims this this is just
completely outrageous
she
said that first of all she does soft
anti-semitic propaganda repeats Russian
propaganda and also starts to take a
sort of Supernatural occult demonic
perspective on what is happening you
have to see this to believe it let's
just jump into the first clip and by the
way this is all happening on real
America's voice so even the venue in
which the conversation is happening is
whacked uh take a listen something is
very wrong with Lara Logan what troubles
me about the moment that we're in is
that we have such a selective and a
narrow reading of History you know
president zielinski may be Jewish but
he's not the only one in this who
suffered during the second world war
whose ancestors suffered right I mean
look at Putin How many relatives did he
lose in the siege of Saint Petersburg so
so right off the bat
zelenski may be Jewish there may be a
history of anti-Semitism but other
people have also suffered like Putin oh
okay all right go go on people don't
know their history they don't know what
made Vladimir Putin and I'm not a
defense you know I'm not defending him I
don't need to defend that if you have
Putin well these are sort of the soft
apologia that we've seen of Putin and
it's also not that heavily veiled
anti-semitic stuff and stuff as well I
mean what what is it zelenski's Jewish
butt I mean what what is she even
talking about and then it really goes
off the rails if you think this is wacky
just wait my job as a journalist is to
try to understand what is the truth here
I don't like being lied to and we're
being lied to on an epic scale when
we're told your only choices you have to
be a hundred percent with zelenski who's
a puppet who you can find on the
internet in black stilettos and leather
pants you know with shirtless doing a
spoof Dancing with the Stars kind of
entertainment video that's a mock of a
Ukrainian group that does this kind of
satanic occult type of music video so
now she's raising that zielinski's been
involved in satanic occult stuff
that's completely outrageous the guy was
a comedian okay now you could say well a
comedian shouldn't be president or you
might say a failed businessman shouldn't
be president sure but we can have that
conversation uh but what on Earth is she
talking about what on Earth is she
talking about and I mean zielinski was
selected like so many of our leaders and
honestly with with big Tech and with
election fraud these days we don't know
how many leaders all around the world
have been selected for us and now that's
another one of these
um Russell's teapot sort of we talked
about Russell's teapot yesterday
she doesn't actually have any evidence
that zielinski won
due to election fraud or due to Big Tech
she doesn't have any evidence if she had
it I guess she would present it although
I don't know maybe she doesn't even care
about evidence I'm not sure but it's
accepted by Ed Henry and the host oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and it puts
everybody else in the position of having
to disprove that zelenski won dude it's
the same thing that they do here but
actually voted in but what we do know is
that there are increasing problems with
technology and the digitization of our
world because look at what's happening
with covet okay you know what has
happened globally we are fighting the
same battles all over the world to
pretend that this war is about Russia
and Ukraine is a just a bare-faced lie
so there's a lot of really important
things here one of the themes these
people all have the same themes right
one of the themes is you're not being
told the truth and you it may not even
be possible to know the truth because
there's so many people trying to lie to
you and all these different things and
it's sort of hard hard to know that
number two making situations that are
about something appear to be far more
complicated than they are now is this
when you think about the history and
fall of the USSR Vladimir Putin's
personal history the history of Ukraine
um the history of NATO the history of
you there there's a lot there and
there's a lot of history to know
but all of these it's too complicated to
even understand it type analyzes
are designed to softly make people
question whether Russia was wrong to
invade Ukraine
um and let's go to the uh we'll go to
one more clip here
um and here I mean this is I cannot
emphasize how Bonkers this interview is
I mean this is on
throughout the Ukrainian measure you can
see that black son of the occult on
their body armor even on the female
soldiers who are paraded in front of the
world as being you know such an example
of Ukraine's Independence and spirit and
nobility it's all satanic and it's all
the occult it's all crazy I mean it's
it's half a step before saying there are
Ukrainian witches and we've got to burn
them when they are wearing the black son
of the occult I mean this is on yeah
so completely off the rails Lara Logan
and I I've I mean listen every time I
talk about her if I if I don't mention
this people email me and say I'm wrong
to mention it
I'm sorry if I don't if I don't mention
it people say I'm wrong not to mention
it but when I mention it people say that
doesn't really matter she's out of her
mind Lara Logan was assaulted I believe
it was when she was covering the uh
revolution in Egypt that's terrible
she may be suffering PTSD any anything
may be going on
her perspective on covet has been
whacked I mean just whacked and now this
kind of like veiled anti-Semitism Putin
apologia their satanic occult stuff
going on this is wacky wacky stuff and
to whatever degree this has to do with
what she experienced I don't know but
I'll put it all out there we'll have
these clips on our Instagram which you
can find at davidpackman show one of our
sponsors is nebia who's introducing
their newest shower head the nebula by
mon cuatro it was designed by former
NASA Engineers who spent years
researching how to save water cuatro is
the world's best high pressure water
saving shower head starting at just 119
and Quattro uses 40 to 50 percent less
water than traditional shower heads
helping the planet helping your wallet
still giving you the high pressure water
stream you love with four different
spray modes literally takes one to two
minutes to install easy as screwing in a
light bulb I love it I have the rain
shower version I've been using nebia
shower heads for a while now I love
saving the water and I love the high
pressure spray it's really The Best of
Both Worlds nebia the maker of cuatro
also offers sustainable bathroom
accessories I have the soft gray bath
mat and the nebula double shelf the
Quattro shower head is just 109 nineteen
dollars but nebia is giving you ten
percent off when you go to nebia.com
Pacman and use the promo code Pacman the
link is underneath this video